listen  you know you need to get sober that  elevator's going down  and there's no guarantee that if you  decide to drink or use tonight that  you're gonna wake up the next day all  bets are off every time you decide to  take that substance into your body there  is a good chance that something terrible  is going to happen in your life and  that's something that you can't control  find somebody you can talk to go out for  coffee with them be honest with them  find a sponsor start getting into the  steps now break it down into what you're  doing today is your head going to hit  the pillow tonight sober or isn't it  what can you control in your exact  present moment  that is going to set you up for  being the the most sober person you can  be